Stromboli is not happy with the tangled
math but then the crowd reacts very
positively and then that confuses the
conscience because he thinks well look
this is horrible this guy's a tyrant
like Pinocchio is making a fool of
himself everything turns into a tangled
mess but the crowd goes crazy and well
being a fool that can be entertaining
right so it's hard to tell when a crowd
especially out of spectacle because
that's this crowd is that a spectacle
you just don't know exactly why it is
that they're responding positively but
you've definitely given what you want
and you can see this look on Stromboli's
face it's like this false again it's
false kindness and generosity
public-facing and oh well anyways the
conscience is very confused and I really
think this is an important thing because
I've often thought I spent a lot of time
thinking about Hitler and I was thinking
well how do you get into a state like
that you know and you think well he's a
dictator and he led his people down a
bad path it's like that's not right that
is not what happened they had a
conspiracy together and went down a bad
path now think about it this way if one
person thinks something about you it's
like whatever right but if five people
tell you that well what then then to
start to start not taking that seriously
it's kind of narcissistic right and if
it isn't five let's say it's 15 people
tell you the same thing or act the same
way towards you it's like probably you
should clue in well what if you're a
politician and you're trying out a bunch
of different ideas and you're good at
interacting with the crowd you're
charismatic you watch the crowd but
you're not necessarily all that
articulate you don't have your values
all straight now but you're kind of
angry too and maybe that's because you
spent a bunch of time in world one in
war one world war one in the trenches
which was like no joke and all your
friends got blown up you and then you
were unemployed and then you tried to be
an artist and that didn't work out even
though you were moderately talented and
then maybe the economy fell apart
completely on you hyperinflation and
then maybe there was a communist menace
coming in from the east and there
genuinely was and so you're not the
world's happy
is clam at that point and you're talking
to people who aren't that happy either
because they were all so badly defeated
in World War one and then they had a
terrible treaty they had decided they
lost part of their territory and so the
crowds not happy and neither are you and
there's reason for it and so you start
talking to them you don't know what
you're upset about and neither does the
crowd so you start to articulate some
things about why you might be upset and
some of them fall flat but you're paying
attention to the crowd so you stop
saying those things and some of the
things make the crowd really wake up and
listen and so you start saying more of
those things right it's a it's it's an
unconscious dialectic between you and
the crowd it's mediated by consciousness
but it's not like you're sitting there
saying although you might be I'm going
to tell this crowd more what it wants to
hear it's more sophisticated than that
and so you do that thousand times and
you do that to ever-increasing crowds
and the crowd really starts to go mad
and they basically tell you that you're
the savior of the nation it's like at
what how many bloody people have to tell
you that before you start to believe it
you know I would say with a typical
person a hundred will do it now get you
going man a hundred people tell you
specifically why you're special you're
going to be thinking even if you're kind
of humble to begin with you're going to
be thinking geez there's got to be
something to this man but if it's a
million people and they're roaring their
approval well and then when it's a whole
nation it's like good luck withstanding
that there's just not a chance
how are you going to withstand that now
you could be like Gandhi and you could
have taken that into account beforehand
because he did he read Tolstoy by the
way he was a student of Tolstoy and
that's very interesting because Tolstoy
was the person who developed the
techniques of non-violence that can be
used and Tolstoy was also a deeply
religious writer being apart from his
novels which are not I wouldn't say
really in the religious category
although they're profound
hmm Tolstoy stressed humility with
non-violence he really stressed it and
that's what Gandhi took to heart so he
lived a very
very very simple bare-bones aesthetic
life and that was to kind of see if he
could keep his damn ego tamp down
well the groundswell was building behind
him you know when he dressed really
simply and he didn't own much and he ate
very simply and he just tried to stay
away from the whole materialistic
success element that would be an element
of what would turn him into an actor and
also inflate his ego and you know he
seemed to do that pretty well you know
he certainly well he led a nonviolent
revolution that resulted in the in the
independence of India it also produced a
terrible civil war in the separate
separation of the Muslim Indians from
the Hindu Indians and but I don't think
you can precisely lay that at the feet
of Gandhi right but but what I'm saying
is that you have to be an extraordinary
person you have to be extraordinarily
wise and you have to take ridiculous
precautions if you're going to put
yourself in the public sphere like that
and expose yourself to that kind of
adulation without becoming a puppet of
the crowd and that's what happened to
Hitler I mean it's not like he wasn't
also a conscious manipulator and
surrounded himself by people who are
propagandists and all of that so there
was a conscious element but you got to
think these things through and see how
that dialectic develops like he learned
how to appeal to the darkest fantasies
of the crowd he was really really good
at it and that was a dialectic process
right the crowd told him what they
wanted to hear and it's the crowds a mob
at that point so I don't have to take
responsibility for the fact that I'm
screaming my approval when I'm
surrounded by a million people so I can
scream my approval for whatever I want
forever whatever dark revengeful fantasy
might be playing out in my imagination
because I'm not going to be held
accountable for it